THE THIRTEENTH. LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE TO ORDER.
I HAVE A SECTION FOR CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE KALRA HERE FLORA.
CARILLO HERE THE- GONZALEZ.
JONES SAWYER SONG THREE OF US.
THE STAFF PERSON THREE OF US.
I'M STATUS WE HAVE. AN ITEM
FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER GONZALEZ
EIGHTY ONE SEVENTY. WE JUST
RECEIVED FROM THE SENATE SIDE
AND IT'S A WITHOUT
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CHAIR.
AND PASSED HIS HIS OFFICE. THE
BILL THAT CAN. THIS IS MY BILL
I'M ADAMANTLY OPPOSED TO IT I
THINK IT IS A DISGRACE THAT THE
SENATE SHOVED DOWN MY THROAT.
TO PRESENT HERE TODAY BECAUSE
SOMETIMES FARMWORKERS HAVE
NOBODY IS YEAH. AND THIS IS ONE
OF THE STATE. THE DYNAMICS
DECISION WAS CLEARLY WRITTEN
WITH THESE TYPES OF WORKERS OF
MINE. WORKERS WHO EVERY SINGLE
DAY EVERY SINGLE DAY SEVEN DAYS
A WEEK THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE
DAYS A YEAR OUR MISCLASSIFIED
BY THEIR EMPLOYER. AND FORCED
TO WORK UNDER CONDITIONS THAT
NONE OF US WOULD BELIEVE IN
FIRST SUB MINIMUM WAGE. AFTER
YEARS AND YEARS OF. THE
NEWSPAPER INDUSTRY
MISCLASSIFIED WORKERS WHATEVER
I LOVE IT IS CLEAR UNDER
FINANCES THEY CANNOT. FIVE FIVE
ABC TEST AND SO AS A RESULT OF
NOT GETTING AN EXEMPTION OUT OF
AB FIVE IN A TRADITIONAL WAY
THEY CHOSE TO WEAPONIZE. IF YOU
JUST. IN A WAY THAT HAS CAUSED
US TO COME TO A POSITION WHERE
I WAS FORCED TO I'M NOT A BILL.
AS A CONDITION OF GETTING AB
FIVE OFF THE FLOOR OF THE
SENATE AND PRACTICES OF. MANY
OF WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. SIR
CHAIR OF THE RIVER JIM YOU WERE
PROBABLY USED PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN FOR CARRYING
THE THREAT TO THE INDUSTRY. IS
POWERFUL SADDAM IS STILL SECRET.
NEWSPAPERS HAVE BEEN STRUGGLING
FOR QUITE A FEW YEARS NOW AND
THIS WILL GIVE US SOME GREEN
SPACE TO COME UP WITH. MODEL
THAT IT COULD WORK FOR THE
VALUES EXPRESSED IN AB FIVE AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE LEGISLATURE. IN THE ONE.
THIS GIVES TO US ON TO GET THAT
DONE AND WE HAVE TO HAVE A.
ANYONE ELSE PARDON ME ASSURE
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY HASN'T HELPED
THE STATE PROGRAM CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL. BEING THE ONE
OF THE STRONGEST SUPPORTER OF
EIGHTY FIVE. WE REALIZE. THE
TWELFTH AND DELICATE PROCESS TO.
WORK WITH INDUSTRY AND TRY TO
FIGURE OUT THAT SORT OF MIDDLE
GROUND TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
FIGHT WAS GOING TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUES FOR ALL WORKERS. THIS IS
A PART OF THE NEGOTIATION. TO
ALLOW AB ONE SEVENTY TO HAVE A
ONE YEAR DELAY OF THE
MEDITATION OF THE PEOPLE I WORK
WITH COMPLETELY FOR THE
NEWSPAPER INDUSTRY. BOB AND
HAVING CONVERSATIONS WITH. THE.
THE ADVOCATES FOR THE INDUSTRY
WILL BE. THAT THEY MUST BE HELD
TO A HIGHER STANDARD. AND ALSO
COME TO THIS COMMITTEE AND TALK
ABOUT A TRANSITION RATHER THAN
JUST A DELAY FOR ONE YEAR WHERE
THERE'S A CON ABILITY FOR FAIR
CONTRACTING POLICIES WHETHER
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS AND
ALSO TO LOOK AT IT THERE ARE
VIOLATIONS OF EMPLOYEE RIGHTS
WHETHER THEY'RE CONVERTING
THOSE INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS
FROM FOR USE AND TRULY MAKING
SURE THAT THE BUSINESS OF THEIR
CLAIM OUR BUSINESS AS AN
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR. ARE
SUCH SO THAT MEANS FROM THE
DISTRIBUTION ALL THE WAY DOWN
TO THE KERRIER AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THEIR COMMITMENTS TO
YOURSELF AND OTHERS I THINK GO
A LONG WAY AND. WERE OPEN
DISCUSS CONTINUES OVER THE
REASON WE ASK. THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT. ANYONE IN
OPPOSITION. IT WOULDN'T TAKE
THAT SEAT THE END THERE. HI FI
AXES GOOD EVENING EVERYONE
MONIES TO TRACK LITTLE I AM AN
ATTORNEY WITH THE LAW FIRM OF
POTTER HE NEEDS. AND SINCE
PERSONALLY JULY OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN ANTI REPRESENTS A
WOMAN BY THE NAME OF FIFTY
ARONSON WHO I SAID HOME AND TO
ACT UPON ACTUALLY DO TELL YEAH
SHE SEVENTY YEARS OLD SO SHOULD
HAVE A LONG DAY MISS ARONSON
HAD WORK HAS WORKED ADAM HAD
WORKED AS A NEWSPAPER CARRIER.
THANK YOU. LOSING YOUR FUN JOB.
AS A RETIREE AND SHE DID IT FOR
THE DESERT SUN WHICH IS
CONTROLLED BY CANON WHICH IS A-
COMPANY THAT MAKES
APPROXIMATELY. A BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR AND PROFIT AS A
NEWSPAPER CARRIER SHE WORKED
SEVEN DAYS A WEEK THREE HUNDRED
SIXTY FIVE DAYS A YEAR. FOR THE
A YEAR AND A HALF SHE WAS THERE.
AND SHE WOULD SHOW UP TO THE
DISTRIBUTION CENTER WHICH
WASN'T HE DID FOR HER COOL. AND
PICKED UP HER USE PAPER AND
PAKISTANIS PAPERS WHEN THEY
CAN'T WANTED TO. AND SHE DROVE.
JOHNNY CARD SHE DROVE. FROM
HOUSE TO HOUSE TO HOUSE SHE WAS
TOLD YEAH AND WAS PAID BETWEEN
TEN CENTS. THIRTY CENTS PER
HOUSE IT SHOULD DELIVER TO. IF
YOU MISS THE DELIVERY. YEAH IT
WOULD TAKE A POP OUT OF.
PERHAPS IF SHE WANTED TO QUIT.
GET IT WOULD CHARGER CHARGE FOR
HUNDRED AND FIFTY DOLLARS SHE
MISSED TODAY YEAH CHARGE FOR A
HUNDRED DOLLARS CHIEF FOREIGN
CAR SHAPE FROM CELL PHONE TWO
IN GPS GENOCIDE TABLET. FROM
FROM CANADA AS WELL I. AND ALL
AROUND EXPENSE. AT AND I WOULD
LIKE TO SAY THAT THIS WAS RARE
BUT THIS IS. EVERYTHING I JUST
TOLD YOU WAS BASED ON THE
CONTRACT THAT SHE WAS REQUIRED
TO SIGN TO BE IN THE STATE HERE
AGAIN. SO SHE WAS ONE OF FIVE
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN
INDIVIDUALS. WITHIN AFFECTED BY
THIS COMPANY WHICH HAS ITS
ANNUAL REVENUE THREE BILLION
DOLLARS. IN ANNUAL PROFIT FOR
BILLION DOLLARS. AND IF YOU
LOOK AT THE COURSE OF
CALIFORNIA HISTORY AND THE CASE
LAW IS COME OUT YOU WILL FIND.
USES NEWSPAPER CARRIERS HAVE
GONE ON. THE POLICE CASE I
THINK NINETEEN TWENTY EIGHT.
NOW I UNDERSTAND THE NEED FOR
USE. I UNDERSTAND REPORT. BUT
AB ONE SEVENTY DOESN'T PROTECT
NEWSPAPERS PROTECTS NEWSPAPER
DISTRICT. AND SO AND THOSE
COMPANIES GIVE ME FOR SURE. THE
OTHER THING I WOULD MENTION. SO
THAT WE TALK ABOUT EIGHTY FIVE
AND THAT THE DYNAMICS THE SIX
MINUTES DYNAMIC FIVE ON THAT
FROM DEFENSE COUNSEL. A LOT OF
YOU ONCE. ANYWAY ON THIS THE
DYNAMICS DECISION WE THINK THAT
THAT IS BEING SHOP. BREAK
EVERYTHING DOWN. AND I'M GONNA
TELL YOU. THE STATE OF
MASSACHUSETTS IS USED AGENCIES
HAVE BACKED AWAY THAT HE FIVE
DOLLARS. SINCE TWO THOUSAND
FIVE YOUR STILL NEWSPAPER
MASSACHUSETTS. ANOTHER ELEVEN
DOLLARS USE THE AB TEST ABC
TESTED ONE WAY OR ANOTHER
FUNDING PLAN INSURANCE IS
COMPENSATION AND THERE ARE
STILL NEWSPAPERS IN THE STATE'S.
ARE SO. AND SO. RECHARGE THE
IDEA THAT AB. ONE SEVENTY IF WE
GIVE THE NEWSPAPERS AN EXTRA
YEAR CLEAN UP THEIR ACT. YAHOO
THE WHITE WILL THE CLOUDS APART
AND EVERYONE WILL UNDERSTAND
WHAT'S GOING ON. IS IT GOING TO
WORK. AS I SAID THE VERY FIRST
CASE ON THIS HE NOW NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT THERE'S ACTUALLY
THERE'S ACTUALLY A BROADWAY
PLAY ABOUT THE ABUSES OF A
NEWSPAPER DELIVERY A NEWSPAPER
CARRIERS. ON CALL PAPER PLATES
EXCEPT IN CALIFORNIA THEY WERE
NEVER NEVER NEVER PAPER THEY'RE
ALWAYS ADULTS BECAUSE THIS IS A
BIG STATE. AND PEOPLE HAVE TO
DRIVE EVERYWHERE EVEN EVEN THE
NINETEEN THIRTIES AND THE
NINETEEN FORTIES NINETEEN
FIFTIES. AND SO ON AND SO FORTH.
I'M SORRY WAY I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR HEARING ME OUT
TONIGHT. AND YEAH. AND I
CERTAINLY HOPE YOU RECONSIDER.
WHAT THE SENATE HAS PUT FORWARD
I THINK. IS THE IDEA THAT
SOMEHOW AGAIN. WE CAN JUST
IGNORE THIS ISSUE FOR ANOTHER
YEAR. IT IS COSTS SO MUCH MORE.
I THINK IT IS A REAL PROBLEM
AND BY THE WAY IN A LAWSUIT
OVER SEATING IS REALLY JUST THE
BARE MINIMUM WE'RE NOT SEEKING
ADDITIONAL. L. ROCK WERE
BASICALLY SEEKING. TWO THREE MS
AARONSON AND HER CO WORKERS. UP
TO THE MINIMUM WAGE. SHE ON
AVERAGE EARN ABOUT THREE
DOLLARS NOW. WORKING THREE
HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS A YEAR
NO WEEKENDS AND HOLIDAYS. THANK
YOU AGAIN. AND. HAVE A GOOD DAY.
THANK YOU MISTER I KNOW THAT
YOU WENT TO SOME TROUBLE TO
COME HERE UNDER VERY SHORT VERY
SHORT NOTICE AND THANK YOU FOR
ADVOCACY. FOR THE WORKERS
REPRESENTING THEM. ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION. BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS. THANK
YOU FOR THE VERY POWERFUL
PRESENTATION. YOU KNOW THE
INTERESTING PART ABOUT BEING A
LEGISLATOR IS THAT WE ALL COME
FROM DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS I AM
A FORMER JOURNALIST. I
GRADUATED IN TWO THOUSAND NINE
WHEN OVER FOUR HUNDRED
NEWSPAPERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
SHUT DOWN. IT WAS ACTUALLY VERY
HARD FOR ME TO GET A JOB. SO I
RAN FOR OFFICE. YEAH AND THE
INTERESTING PART ABOUT THAT IS
THAT. AS SOMEBODY THAT
BELIEVES. IN THE POWER OF THE
PRESS POWER OF MEDIA THE POWER
OF A JOURNALIST IS SEEN THE
LAST FEW YEARS. JOURNALIST BE
KICKED OUT OF POLITICAL PRESS
CONFERENCES BE KICKED OUT OF
THE WHITE HOUSE. AND KNOW THAT
OUR DEMOCRACY IS SO DEPENDENT.
ON JOURNALISTS TO TELL THE
STORY TO THE PUBLIC. WE DON'T
GET THAT. JUST SIMPLY BECAUSE
SOMEBODY AS A JOURNALIST RIGHT
SAID AND GET SOME MINOR GETS ON
A PAPER IT RELIES ON COPY
EDITORS RESEARCHERS. THE VERY
PEOPLE THAT DELIVER THE
NEWSPAPER THAT GETS TO OUR
HANDS THAT GETS TO THIS
BUILDING. SO I'M I'M SADDENED
THIS WAS ALL IS THAT YOU HAD TO
TAKE THIS AMENDMENT TO MOST
SOMETHING. THAT IS INCREDIBLY
POWERFUL FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AS WE- THINK ABOUT.
WORKERS IN THE FUTURE WORK
ACROSS THE STATE. AND I REALLY
DO HOPE MISTER YOU WERE THAT WE
CAN. WORK TOGETHER AND KNOW
THAT. THERE ARE SEVERAL OF US
THAT WILL BE LOOKING TO YOU.
AND HOLD YOUR INDUSTRY
ACCOUNTABLE TO ENSURE THAT YOU
ARE GETTING THIS ONE YEAR EXTRA.
BUT THAT THE WORKERS THAT
DELIVER THE NEWSPAPERS THAT WE
ALL RELY ON FOR OUR DEMOCRACY
WORK. ACTUALLY OUR
REPRESENTATIVE HAVE AT THE VERY
MINIMUM MINIMUM WAGE. AND SO WE
WILL. THE VOTING ON THIS AND
I'LL SEE HOW IT GOES ON THE
FLOOR. BUT AS SOMEBODY THAT HAS
WORKED IN THAT INDUSTRY AND
KNOWS THAT FROM A RESEARCHER TO
A COPY EDITOR TO. ORDER TO THE
PRINT SHOP TO THE MECHANICS TO
THE DELIVERY. ACTUALLY GETTING
THE PAPER IN OUR HANDS. AND TO
KNOW THAT THIS THE STORY OF
THIS WOMAN WHO WAS PAID ON
AVERAGE THREE DOLLARS AN HOUR.
THAT IS NOT OUR DEMOCRACY THAT
IS NOT HOW. ANYONE SHOULD BE
GETTING PAID AND SO AS AS-
EXCELLENT CONVEY THAT TO YOU
THAT THAT THE INTERESTING PART
ABOUT BEING IN IN THIS POSITION
NOW IS THAT WE DO ALL COME FROM
DIFFERENT BACKGROUNDS AND SOME
OF US UNDERSTAND DIFFERENT
INDUSTRIES. A LITTLE BIT MORE
PERSONALLY. FIVE I LOOK FORWARD
TO WHAT THE NEXT YEAR BRINGS IN
TERMS OF BRINGING. THE
NEWSPAPER INDUSTRY INTO THE
TABLE AND HOLDING. HOLDING
ACCOUNTABLE TO MAKE SURE THAT
ALL WORKERS ARE PAID FAIRLY.
THANK YOU THIS IS THE SENSOR
AND A HALF AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CALL. AND I CAN. STANDS
GONZALEZ IS CONCERNED AND. AS A
FORMER PAPER BOY. IN HARTFORD
CONNECTICUT DELIVERING PAPERS
THREE HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE DAYS A
WEEK DESPITE ACE THE YEAR FOR
TWO YEARS I'M TALKING ABOUT IN
THE SUMMER WHEN IT'S HOT IS.
AND YOU KNOW WHAT TO KEEP IT IN
THE WINTER WHEN IT'S COLD AS
HELL DELIVERING NEWSPAPERS THE
FACT THAT YOU'RE STILL PAYING
THEM WHAT I WAS GETTING PAID IN
THE SIXTIES. IS RIDICULOUS.
THAT'S WHAT I WAS MAKING BACK
THEN IN THE SIXTIES WHAT THIS
WOMAN IS MAKING NOW. YES WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND DO THIS WHEN
YOU BUT YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND.
JUST LIKE THE PAPERS SIGNED THE
LIGHT ON US. THIS LIFE NOW BEEN
SHINED ON THE NEWSPAPER
INDUSTRY. AND YOU HAVE THREE
HUNDRED AND SIXTY FIVE DAYS TO
GET THIS RIGHT. BECAUSE IF YOU
LOOK AT. MY COLLEAGUES FACES
WE'RE NOT GONNA LET THIS GO.
AND LIKE I ALWAYS SAY IN EVERY
MEETING YOU NEVER EVER EVER
NEVER EVER. ONE ELECTED
OFFICIAL TO FIX YOUR PROBLEM.
WITH WORSE. AND I MEAN THAT. I
REALLY DO MEAN THAT YOU NEVER
EVER EVER WANT US TO INTERFERE
AND WHEN I HEAR BUSINESSES AND
MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE OTHER
SIDE SAY WE SHOULD BE INVOLVED
AND STUFF. IS BECAUSE. THAT
INDUSTRY DOESN'T FIX THEIR
STUFF. I WANT TO SAY SOMETHING.
SO THE LEAST YOU HAVE TIME TO
GET IT RIGHT AND IF YOU DON'T.
THAT LIGHT BEEN SKITTISH TURNED
AROUND ON YOU. AND THEY WILL
COME UP WITH THINGS THAT MAKE
IT SO BAD YOU WISH YOU. YOU
WOULD NEVER CUT IS. RIGHT AND
SO I IMPLORE YOU. HI COREY TO
FIX THIS IN A FIX THIS QUICK SO
THAT. WE DON'T HAVE TO DO THAT.
THANK YOU. FIRST YOU KNOW I'D
LIKE TO COMMEND THE OFF HER FOR
HER WORK OVER THE PAST YEAR ON
THE EIGHTY FIVE YOU KNOW I
HEARD FROM YOU OF YOUR STORIES
AND HAVE WITNESSED THE WORK OF
YOUR HANDS YOU KNOW THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE BEHIND
THIS ANY OF THIS YEAR I LEARNED
A LOT ABOUT WORKERS AND WHAT
EIGHTY FIVE WILL DO FOR
ESPECIALLY FROM SOME OF THAT
DON'T HAVE ANYBODY THAT
REPRESENTS THEM. RIGHT AND I
THINK OF MY CONSTITUENTS SWITCH
A LOT OF MY CONSTITUENTS ARE
NOT IN C. BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT
IN A PROFESSION THAT REPRESENTS
THEM AND. WHEN I RAN FOR OFFICE
I RAN FOR THEM. AND. AND I AM
HERE TO REPRESENT THEM AND- I
SEE. IN THE MORNINGS I SEE
PEOPLE WITH THEIR FAMILIES.
WAKING UP REALLY EARLY TAKING
THEIR KIDS ON HOPE FOR SCHOOL
AND THROWING OUT THE NEWSPAPERS
AND TO THINK THAT THAT WHOLE
FAMILY WORKING TOGETHER IS
MAKING THREE DOLLARS AN HOUR IS
JUST AN ACCEPTABLE. AND YOU
KNOW THESE ARE PEOPLE THAT.
OURS ARE COUNTING ON SO I NEED
TO REPRESENT THEM AND I CAN.
THERE ARE OTHER INDUSTRIES THAT
DID NOT GET AN EXTRA YEAR TO
THINK ABOUT THIS INCLUDING
INDUSTRIES THAT I THOUGHT MAYBE
SHOULD OF LIKE DESIGN
PROFESSIONALS SCIENTISTS THAT
WERE ALL OVER THAT GET PAID ARE
HIGHLY SKILLED AND HIGHLY PAID
AND ARE FORTUNATE TO HAVE
PEOPLE THAT REPRESENT THEM. AND
WHO ARE THE LAST HOUR I'M DOING
THIS FOR PEOPLE THAT DON'T
HAVE. THAT TO REPRESENTATION
AND I JUST. YOU KNOW I DON'T
UNDERSTAND WHY WE'RE DOING. AND
SO. IT'S VERY HARD FOR ME TO
SUPPORT THIS. BECAUSE I THINK
OF THOSE WORKERS THEY DON'T
HAVE ANYONE. FANS IT'S JUST A
VERY TOUGH IT AND I HOPE THAT
THIS NEXT YEAR THAT. THEN THE
NEWSPAPER DISTRIBUTORS AND THIS
INDUSTRY REALLY COMES UP WITH A
PLAN THAT. LIKE MY COLLEAGUES
EXPRESSED WILL. WE'LL PAID A
FAIR WAGE. TO THESE JUST PLEASE
WORKERS. THANK YOU THE OTHER
COMMENT. I JUST SAY LOOK I JUST
LIKE TO SAY THAT I'VE HAD THE
DISTINCT PROVISION HONOR OF
HAVING A FRONT ROW SEAT
WATCHING A SUMMER LEARNING
GONZALEZ. AS AS SHE HAS FOUGHT
HARDER THAN ANYONE I'VE EVER
SEEN IN MY LIFE FOR WORKERS.
AND WAY THAT SOME POWERFUL THE
WAY THAT IN A MATTER WHAT SHE'S
BEEN. DILLON EYES DEMONIZED.
AND YET CONTINUES TO FIGHT
BECAUSE SHE KNOWS THAT SHE'S
FIGHTING FOR PEOPLE THAT DON'T
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE SIGNING UP
FOR THEM. FOR THE SENATE TO PUT
HER IN THIS POSITION I THINK IS
BENEATH. DIGNITY OF LEGISLATION
WE SERVICE. I GET POLITICS I
UNDERSTAND THAT HAPPENS I
UNDERSTAND THAT WE HAVE RULES
OF PROCEDURES AND WE HAVE
DIFFERENT WAYS FOR. LEGISLATORS
TO BE ABLE TO PUSH THEIR AGENDA
AND I GET ALL THAT I'M NOT
NAIVE TO THE- BUT FOR THEM TO
DO THIS TO OUR COLLEAGUE. WAS
ALWAYS HOLD HER SUB HIGH ENOUGH
THAT HONORABLY AND I'M IN A IN
A SELFLESS MANNER. I THINK IS.
I UNDERSTAND THE POSITION
RUNNING AS WELL WHICH IS IT IS
IT THIS IS NOT JUST OF THE
PROPOSITION THAT. THE AUTHORS
PUT AND IT'S IT IS DIFFICULT
JUST NOT BUT IT'S AWESOME. AND
OUR SPEAKER AND OF THE ASSEMBLY
AS A WHOLE BECAUSE. OF THE
MANNER IN WHICH. THIS BILL IS
MOVE FORWARD AND I GET THE LOOK
THIS INDUSTRY IS NOT UNIQUE
THERE'S DOZENS OF OTHER
INDUSTRIES THAT I'VE- ASKED
MORE TIME AND ASK FOR
EXEMPTIONS IS SO. THIS IS ONE
OF MANY BUT THE DIFFERENCE IS
THAT THIS INDUSTRY DOES HAVE. A
LOT OF POWER AND INFLUENCE AND
THAT'S ALSO IS NOT SOMETHING
UNIQUE TO. TODAY THAT'S
CERTAINLY NOT IN THIS BUILDING.
I DO TAKE THE INDUSTRY HAS
WORDING CONVERSATIONS WE'VE HAD
IN TERMS OF WHAT WE- HOPE TO
ACCOMPLISH WITH THIS YEAR.
THERE'S GREAT OPPORTUNITY IN IN
EVEN EVEN IF THE PROCESS IS A
MESSY ONE THAT WE DON'T. WE
DON'T LIKE. IT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT THE END RESULT HAS TO BE
SOMETHING WE DON'T LIKE. AND SO
COME. YOU KNOW I'M CERTAINLY
COMMITTED TO ENSURE THAT THIS
pTHAT WE THINK ABOUT THE WORKER
AND THE WORKERS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING WHEN WE THINK ABOUT.
WHAT WE WANT AND RESOLVED TO
LOOK LIKE. THE NEW CIVIC
INDUSTRY USUALLY PLACES A
SPOTLIGHT ON OTHERS AND AS
INDICATED BY SOME JONES SAWYER.
THE SPOTLIGHT IS NOW ON ON THEM
IN TERMS OF. HOW THIS NEXT YEAR
WILL LOOK LIKE AS IT RELATES.
TO MISS CLASSIFICATION AS IT
RELATES TO THE. I NAPA DYNAMICS
AND THE WORK THAT THE
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF WORK THE
NOT JUST SOME RUDY SALAS HAS
BROUGH THIS FOR THE SPEAKER'S
OFFICE. CERTAINLY MY STAFF HERE
THE LABOR COMMITTEE BUT ALSO
THE LABOR FEDERATION THE
BUILDING TRADES AND THIS IS NOT
THE THERE'S BEEN A TREMENDOUS
AMOUNT OF WORK PUTTING TRYING
TO GET IT RIGHT AND WE KNOW
WE'RE NOT PERFECT WE KNOW THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO GET
EVERYTHING RIGHT. BUT BUT WE DO
KNOW THAT WE'VE BEEN TRYING
REALLY HARD I KNOW THAT ARE
AUTHOR OF AB FIVE IS BEEN
TRYING HARDER THAN. ANYONE TO
TRY TO GET IT RIGHT. THE
WORKERS AND TO RESPECT THE
SUPREME COURT AS WELL AND THEIR
DECISION. WHICH WE CAN'T LOSE
SIGHT OF THAT IF WE DO NOTHING
AB FIVE DOESN'T. ONCE THAT
HAPPENS. THAT EVERYBODY HAS A.
B. C. TEST SO IT'S NOT A MATTER
OF JUST TRYING TO STICK IT TO
ONE GROUP ONE INDUSTRY OR THE
OTHER. AND THIS IS NOT A MATTER
OF. OF TELLING NEWSPAPERS ANY
OTHER INDUSTRY TO. TO NOT BE
INCLUDED BUT BECAUSE THERE'S-
AN ISSUE WITH OPTICAL
INDUSTRIES BECAUSE THIS IS A
VERY COMPLEX VERY COMPLICATED.
AND THE DAY THE MUSIC INDUSTRY
ITSELF IS NOT A MONOLITH AND IT
HAS A LOT OF COMPLEXITY TO IT
AS WELL. AND I UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGES INCLUDING IT MAYBE
FIVE OF THOSE REASONS. BUT WE
HAVE. HERE SB ONE SEVENTY AND.
I JUST I JUST HOPE THAT AS A
LEGISLATIVE BODY WE CAN DO
BETTER THAT WE DO BETTER. YOU
DO BETTER BY OUR COLLEAGUES.
BECAUSE ALL OF OUR COLLEAGUES
IS ARE BETTER BUT- ESPECIALLY
SOME AMERICANS OFFICERS BETTER.
THAN THAN THIS AND SO. WE HAVE
A MOTION TO THE. CURRENT
STABILITY THE. CORRECT WITHOUT
RECOMMENDATION IS MY
RECOMMENDATION BUT THE MOTION
IS. THE PAST WITH THE WORD
RECEPTIVE. THE GROUND
CONCURRENT CURRENTS OF THE
CURRENT LAW CENTER. YEAH AND
YEAH OF COURSE AND SO BUT AFTER
THE ALSO HAS AN OPPORTUNITY
CLOSE AND CONNECTED YES I JUST
WANT TO BE HONEST YEAH. I YEAH
IT WAS FORCED TO TAKE THIS BILL.
BUT WAS VERY CLEAR THAT I WOULD
NOT SO. AND THAT'S A HIGHLY
UNUSUAL SITUATION BUT IT'S.
WOULD BE FOR ME TO ACTUALLY
CONTEST GIVEN. ZERO EIGHTY FIVE
THAT A LOT OF PEOPLE THOUGHT
MIGHT MAKING THEIR HIKES WITH
PIECEMEAL BUT FACT IT WASN'T
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF THINGS
WE CONSIDERED IN WAYS WE LOOK
AT INDUSTRIES THE NUMBER ONE
TEAM HOW HARD HOW HIGH IS THE
BARRIER TO ENTRY IN A
PROFESSION BUT WOULD BE
EXEMPTED BECAUSE THE HIGHER THE
BARRIERS TO ENTRY OF COURSE THE
MORE INDIVIDUAL LEVERAGED AN
IN. HOUSE FOR PARDON ME. WE
LOOKED AT HOW MUCH PEOPLE MADE
AND IN FACT. THOUGHT THAT YOU
SHOULD BE MAKING JUST LIKE OUR.
OUR STATE LAW REQUIRES TWICE
THE MINIMUM WAGE IN ORDER TO BE
EXEMPT FROM BEING IN PLACE
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT CELERY
EXEMPT. INDIVIDUAL MAKES THEY
HAVE TO MAKE THAT IF YOU DON'T
WORRY ABOUT OVER TIME AND- AND
MET THEY IN MALE BREAKS AND
REST BREAKS. I. ALSO WITH THE
NEWSPAPER GIRL. TWELVE AND
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN I'M- AND IT
WAS ACTUALLY EVEN WORSE THAN IT
IS TODAY HE DID COLLECT ENOUGH
MONEY TO PAY FOR HERE
NEWSPAPERS AND IF YOU DON'T
COLLECT FROM THE INDIVIDUALS
NHIáU. HOW TO COME UP WITH
THE MONEY SO I SPEND A LOT TIME
HUSTLING. TO GET PEOPLE TO PAY
YOU KNOW AND I'M WORKING CLASS
AREA TO GET THEM TO. PAY IN
CASH THE TWELVE YEAR OLD IS WAS
FUN. BUT I HAD TO DO IT. I ALSO.
NO A LOT OF PEOPLE IN AND WE
TALKED A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO IN.
JUST GENERALLY IN COMMUNITIES
LIKE MINE. WHOSE PARENTS HOW TO
DO THIS AS A JOB. WITH KIDS IN
TOW. STARTING AT LIKE THREE IN
THE MORNING. THEY CAN'T PAPERS
EVERY SINGLE DAY. IN ANY OTHER
JOB IF YOU WORK SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK WE EXPECT DOUBLE TIME. THE
NEWSPAPER INDUSTRY. HAS
REALISTICALLY SOMETHING ELSE AS
WELL. FOR DECADES. THEY HAVE
BEEN SUBJECT TO COUNTLESS
LAWSUITS UNDER BRELO. NOW AND
DYNAMAX DYNAMICS. AND THEY
CONTINUE SAY THEY CANNOT THE
FILL. THE OBLIGATIONS OF PAIN
THE LOS WORKERS THE LOWEST PAID
WORKERS THE UNREPRESENTED
WORKERS THE WORKERS TO DO THEIR
WORK OUT OF THE SITE MOST
PEOPLE. ON MINIMUM WAGE.
FURTHERMORE THEY DID USE THEIR.
EDITORIAL PAGES TO COMMAND THE
OVERALL DESIRES OF AB FIVE IN
SAME FACT MOST CERVANTES YOU
KNOW SOMETHING DOES HAVE TO BE
DONE ABOUT THE ECONOMY BUT IT'S
A LOT NOT A WELL THOUGHT OUT
BILL BECAUSE IT WOULD AFFECT.
HE NEVER QUITE GOT TO HAPPEN
BASICALLY. GOOD INTENTIONS BUT
PROBLEMATIC. I SUPPORT
JOURNALISM. TO MY MOST POLICE
YOU KNOW IT TROUBLES ME TO SEE
EVERYTHING THAT'S HAPPENING. I
DON'T WANT TO SEE A NEWS.
CURRENT THAT'S DIANA I DON'T
WANT TO BE PART OF THAT. BUT I
THINK IT'S ALSO HYPOCRITICAL.
FOR THE NEWSPAPERS. RIGHT SAME
DOING SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD
ALL BE PLASTIC FOREIGN
EDITORIALS IF IT WAS ANYTHING
ELSE. END OF SESSION. DARK OF
NIGHT GOT MAN. FOR AN INDUSTRY
WITHOUT RATIONAL THOUGHT
BECAUSE IT FITS INTO NOTHING
ELSE THAT WE'RE GOING TO GIVE A
SPECIAL PRIVILEGE TO. THE FIRST
MOMENTS IMPORTANT. BUT IN
REGARD TO FOR TREATING PEOPLE
LIKE. WE DON'T ALLOW CHURCHES.
TO NOT PAY THEIR WORKERS
MINIMUM WAGE. HE HAS A
RELIGIOUS IN NATURE. SO I JUST
WANT TO BE VERY HONEST I WILL
NOT BE VOTING FOR THIS YEAR
WERE ON THE FLOOR IF IT GETS
OUT. AND I AM SORRY THAT WE ARE
IN THIS POSITION I WOULD LOVE
TO SAY THAT IT WAS AN
ASSOCIATION BUT NEGOTIATIONS
USUALLY HAVE TWO SIDES AND I
HAD. NO OTHER CHOICE. BUDGET
REQUEST FOR. AS A CONDITION OF
BRINGING AND PASSING AB FIVE SO
WITH THAT. THAT'S ABOUT. THANK
YOU. SO WE HAVE THE AT THE
MOTION. THE TURNS WITH SENDING
AMENDMENTS BY SILVER JONES
SAWYER SECOND BY CREEL FROM THE
START WITH THE VICE CHAIR ON
THE BOAT LOCAL NEWS. FLORA.
LARA HI HI CREEL AYE DO YOU.
NOT VOTING. GONZALEZ NOW NOW
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER HI
THE THREE OF US. NOT VOTING. HI
THIS RIVAS I KALRA. NO KALRA
NOW. THE BILL. AS THE FIRST.
RIGHT SO. TO FIND RETURNED